hurricanes are terrifying in part
because they unfold in slow motion
scientists watch them format it see
growing ever bigger and more powerful
then they do their best to predict where
the storm might make landfall and how
powerful it might be but predicting
hurricanes is very difficult so how do
scientists track and predict hurricanes
to find out we sat down with a hurricane
hunter who flies planes into the heart
of these massive storms my name is Jason
dummy and on about research
meteorologists with NOAA's hurricane
research division and with the
University of Miami why would you fly a
big very expensive airplane anywhere
near a hurricane so that's a great
question we have a couple of different
Hurricane Hunters that we like to fly we
do have a high altitude Gulfstream jet
that we fly at about 45,000 feet around
the storm so we don't get too close with
that plan but we do have to p3 so their
p3 Orion's it's an old Navy sub munte
to take a beating it's made to fly low
and hard over the ocean if we just have
satellites maybe a couple of ship
observations out over the ocean you can
almost think of that stage as kind of
the low definition stage where we've got
good information but we don't have the
best information you know flash-forward
to one we're doing hurricane
reconnaissance if the storm gets close
enough and we really wanted to start
picking it apart then we start taking
our aircraft with all the instruments
that we have and kind of turn a low
definition situation into a maybe a 4k
or now we can get up with a full look at
the storm or feeding the models all this
extra data so things really start to
change once we start getting the
aircraft out there and really starting
to pick the storm apart what does it
feel like to fly an aircraft so near to
a hurricane you can get updrafts that
will raise the plane up a few hundred
feet in a matter of seconds down drafts
that push you down and you can actually
get zero gravity things start to to kind
of float for a few seconds while you're
first of all you're strapped in and then
you pop into this eye in this case it
was about ten or twelve miles across and
it's complete calm the clouds break
we've gone from 200 mile-per-hour winds
to maybe five miles per hour
and you can you can even get out of your
seat take some pictures walk around
knowing that you're in the middle of the
storm and if you want to get back out
again you've got to cut through you know
the other size of the hurricane so that
flight sounds pretty dangerous how do
you ensure that everybody the plane is
staying up at the cockpit there are
actually two pilots and a flight
engineer so everyone is adjusting for
the storm and the flight engineer is
actually adjusting the engines whether
we need to go faster or slower so
navigators the meteorologists are trying
to look ahead it know what could be a
more tricky part of the storm as we're
cutting through it so when you put those
19 folks together it becomes a safer
environment because we all really
understand these storms because we've
been flying them so long with that said
it's still not sitting like sitting in
your couch at night watching TV it's a
little bit more exciting than that for
sure and what kind of data are these
aircraft and it seems now more so drones
that you're deploying as well what kind
of data are they collecting that are
useful for building out these models we
have very complex instruments that we
take on board we have little drop zones
that launch out of the planes with a
little parachute pops open and measuring
temperature pressure humidity winds
everything we want to know about the
storm and some of our planes actually
have a tail Doppler radar that's
rotating and it's actually almost think
of it as a cat scan of the storm so
suddenly you're able to paint the wind
field from just above the ocean's
surface all the way up to the top of the
storm up near the stratosphere we have a
microwave instrument that actually looks
at the state of the sea surface and
gives us a wind speed and that's the
all-important information that we want
to get to the hurricane center because
you know winds up at 10,000 feet 20,000
feet they're important for forecasts but
really what does it matter for folks on
the ground we want to know what the
winds are down at the surface and can we
talk about the models how do these work
how are you plugging in data that sort
of thing to to build these predictions
for hurricanes we have several models
some of them look on the global scale
some of them look more what we call a
meso scale where they're just focused in
over the storm with the input the storm
environment
like what what what is really advanced
in recent years is what we call data
assimilation so we're collecting all
these observations you know this 4k
high-def look all these observations
from our Hurricane Hunters but if the
models don't know how to use that data
and really assimilate it into their
forecasts it's really a waste so there
have been some really incredible
advancements as far as how do the models
take that data in and how do they
continuously use it to make their
forecasts that go out you know a few
weeks what do you need to have in order
for these things to fajn warm sea
surface temperature is really moist air
in the mid levels say of maybe 10,000
feet or so kind of favorable winds if
the winds are too strong it can kind of
the storm apart you know if you go back
to the breeding ground over Africa just
south of the Sahara Desert that's really
the nursery for a lot of these songs you
we get these rotating the thunderstorms
that kind of march across the continent
when they come off the coast they start
to bubble up a little bit you start to
see more clouds more convection and as
that storm thunderstorm starts to grow
it starts to draw in more energy more
winds the low levels and it almost
starts to breathe you start to have air
rushing in down low rising up near the
center and then out at the top so you
can almost think of it as this breathing
engine that if the conditions are right
it can really start to ramp up why is it
so important to you know peg down not
only the direction of the hurricane the
path 'taking but also the intensity how
does that then inform efforts on the
ground in preparation for landfall
if you don't have a good track for the
storm and you put the storm in the wrong
place you're gonna have all different
predictors it could be in a colder ocean
area so they kind of come together into
this this all-important forecast where
the track and the intensity are really
closely tied it's not just the winds
that can reach you know a weak tornado
strength actually some of these stronger
storms but it's the inland flooding that
can you know we can get 10 20 inches 30
inches of rain some of these events that
can cause a lot of destruction and even
loss of life and even the storm surge
where people are kind of caught along
the coast so you're you're looking at
these extreme events and if you're
looking at at these category fives
they're the rarest
a rare where you can really start to
affect life loss loss of property along
those coastlines where just by human
nature that's where we tend to flock
that's where people like to live that's
where people like to go on their
vacations so it becomes a really
vulnerable part of our of our world are
these coastlines were of course
hurricanes tend to affect so in these
times of climate change do we have a
good idea yet of how that might be
affecting you know first of all maybe
the way that these hurricanes are
forming and maybe their intensity you
know obviously warmer waters is a big
component of this but what are we
finding as the climate warms how that
might be affecting hurricanes the
climate question is really tricky with
hurricanes because our record goes back
about 100 years or so and our really
solid record where we have satellites
and we've got aircraft that connaissance
that goes back about 50 years so you
know you think about it's kind of a
blink of an eye for mother nature for as
long as we've been looking these storms
and really understanding them but if we
think about a changing environment where
we might have warming certainly one
thing would be warming sea surface
temperatures right we know that's one of
the pieces the ingredients the fuel for
these storms some studies have suggested
if we get into a warmer climate looking
at model simulations that some parts of
the world actually get drier in the
middle levels of the atmosphere while
some get moister so there's maybe a
little bit of a mixed signal there we're
not sure how that would play out and I
think you make it even more complicated
when you put this we know there's this
background oscillations to be storms
it's multi decay --dl where we had kind
of a quiet 60s and 70s 80s and all the
sudden things wrapped up in the 90s and
we're kind of in this this more active
error so the question gets very complex
and we look at all these competing
ingredients for storms plus there's this
natural background oscillation it's
certainly lots more studies need to need
to be done to really try to take a crack
at at what a warming climate could mean
for hurricanes
yeah and Orion was interesting because
it seemed to have slowed down
significantly is that at all a function
of climate change or has that been seen
in the past there are some interesting
recent
studies that have suggested that maybe
some storms would start to slow as they
approach the coast in a warming climate
I think it's too early to really put up
a good handle on that and really say yes
or no one thing's for sure is in the
Dorian case we saw the steering currents
basically break down as it approached
the coast which is kind of a worst case
scenario for a place like the Bahamas
where suddenly there's no forward motion
we have a major category 5 storm that
it's really lost its steering currents
and can cause a lot of storm surge and a
lot of this destruction in the few days
that it's kind of meandering over a
certain area yeah one of the interesting
things I find about hurricanes is a lot
of time you see it kind of steer up the
coast of the eastern United States what
are the phenomena that might be driving
that yes I wanted we call the
subtropical Ridge
meteorologists look to have their fancy
terms but it's really just a
high-pressure system in the middle of
the Atlantic and that's kind of
climatology where this high pressures
just kind of parked throughout the
summer and that helps to steer these
storms generally from east to west from
africa all the way to the United States
but as they start to get to the western
part of the Basin near Cuba and near
Florida they're kind of coming around
the edge of that high pressure so things
can really start to change quickly what
comes next
in hurricane science being an able to
predict rapid intensification better or
even wrap the weekend that's just as
important rainfall forecasts we know
that rainfall is can cause a lot of loss
of life and property getting better
forecast from the models about where
those big precipitation events might set
up and really continuing to develop
observations that can go into those
models so whether it's using high
altitude drones that we've tested out a
little bit like a film called the global
hawk where we're flying in the
stratosphere sampling over the storm so
it's thinking that in the coming years
we're looking at that two-way street
were we continuously try to improve the
types of observations - type types of
pictures that we're providing in the
storm but we come up with models that
can handle that information better and
make better and better
thank you for joining us thanks for
having me appreciate